[Musique]
ingénieur ancienne enseignant
conférencier vous êtes membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat président
fondateur de shift project associés
fondateur de carbone 4 c'est gentil
d'avoir trouvé le temps de devenir nous
rejoindre quel est votre lecture de la
crise économique énergétique pardon
mondiale que nous sommes en train de
traverser qu'elles en sont selon vous
les raisons au-delà du conflit en
Ukraine
en trois secondes
d'abord la première chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que plus le temps va
passer et plus il y a des choses qui
paraissent être des crises qui en fait
ne seront pas des crises ou plus
exactement la crise elle porte l'idée
que on a un accident de parcours qui a
une situation normale sans crise et que
après la crise on revient à la situation
avant l'accident de parcours en fait on
tend ce qui concerne l'énergie qu'en ce
qui concerne le climat c'est deux idées
qu'il faut se sortir de la tête parce
que ça ne correspond pas à ce qui va se
passer en ce qui concerne le climat
l'inertie du système fait que il y a pas
de remise en état possible après
accident dit autrement quand on commence
à avoir des vrais c'est comme bon
parallèles et celui du fumeur c'est à
dire que quand on commence à vous dire
tiens il va falloir qu'on vous enlève un
poumon c'est un peu tard pour dire ben
non finalement j'arrête de fumer puis
c'est je vais retrouver mes poumons
d'avant et en ce qui concerne le
l'énergie en fait ce qui a fait l'essor
de la civilisation moderne c'est le fait
qu'on est utilisé de façon croissante
pas possible fossiles ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui
la neutralité en fait c'est la promesse
d'avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
c'est à dire c'est la promesse de se
débarrasser des combustibles fossiles
tout en gardant la civilisation qui a
été permise par les combustibles
et ces combustible fossiles même si on
ne veut pas s'en débarrasser pour des
raisons de climat le temps de formation
géologique de ces combustibles qui est
de quelques centaines de millions
d'années pour le charbon
qui était formé à partir de Fougères qui
ont poussé à l'ère du charbon le
Carbonifère et 300 millions d'années et
le pétrole et le gaz qui sont des
résidus de plancton qui datent dis à
quelques dizaines à quelques centaines
de millions d'années fait que ces
combustible sont également épuisables
pour des raisons strictement de temps de
formation
donc ce qu'on est en train de vivre de
façon croissante depuis les chocs
pétroliers d'abord et puis surtout le
milieu des années 2000 c'est des
accidents de parcours croissants liés à
la disponibilité de ces combustibles
fossiles qui va devenir de plus en plus
chaotique là dessus je suis pas devin
j'ai pas de boule de cristal donc je
suis pas en train de dire c'est normal
que il se passe qui s'est passé hors
d'Ukraine c'est normal etc par contre ce
que je suis capable de dire c'est que il
est normal que les accidents de parcours
se multiplient parce que à l'occasion
des tensions qui vont s'exercer entre
pays parce que la compétition pour les
ressources va aller croissants de temps
en temps il y aura des marges d'escalier
qui vont être franchis alors je suis pas
capable de dire ou quand comment par
contre ce que je sais c'est que je suis
capable de dire que le monde de demain
va ressemblablement malheureusement être
de plus en plus volatile et que c'est
dans ce contexte là que il faut arriver
à faire ce qu'on arrive à faire de telle
sorte que la situation ne soit pas
encore plus désagréable
quel est votre jugement sur la manière
dont l'Europe a répondu jusqu'à présent
à la crise énergétique on apparaît au
plus pressé avec des aides est-ce qu'on
sait vraiment interrogé sur les
questions de fond non c'est pas
interrogé sur les questions de fond
alors il faut savoir que dans la feuille
de route de la commissaire européenne à
l'énergie
quadrille j'arrive jamais à savoir si
c'est Simpson aussi Mons mais je sais
pas pourquoi j'arrive j'accroche là
dessus
le mot pétrole ne figure pas au moment
où de l'avènement de la nouvelle
Commission j'avais été regardé les
feuilles de route vous savez maintenant
les outils logiciels permettent avec un
petit coup de contrôler de voir très
vite si un mot donné s'y trouve ou pas
non et j'avais pas trouvé le mot pétrole
qui est quand même la première énergie
consommée dans la zone OCDE et la
première énergie consommée en Europe
avec à peu près un tiers de
l'approvisionnement or il se trouve
qu'en ce qui concerne le pétrole les
signaux d'alerte se multiplient depuis
des années en particulier l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie a publié en
2018 un rapport disant le pic de
conventionnel est passé en 2008
conventionnel c'est tout ce qui n'est
pas le chalet américain et
et
à la Commission européenne à chaque fois
que j'ai été donné un coup de sonde sur
comment est-ce qu'ils comprennent la
dépendance européenne aux importations
d'hydrocarbures et les possibilités
physiques indépendamment de toute
conscience de contraintes climatique
d'approvisionnement futur c'est
électroencéphalogramme plat sur la
question de la disponibilité physique
des ressources ça voilà
avant la crise en Ukraine la Russie
c'était 40% de notre gaz 30% de notre
pétrole et 25% de notre charbon
au moment où la guerre est arrivée en
Ukraine on s'est dit bon très bien on
coupe les ponts avec Poutine
sans critiquer le bien fondé ou pas de
cette décision l'Europe c'est pas posé
la question de savoir si ça serait
facile de se retourner ailleurs il se
trouve qu'en ce qui concerne le gaz à
part la Russie on est approvisionné par
des zones qui sont plutôt en déclin or
GNL puisque la mère du Nord est en
déclin depuis 2005 sur le gaz l'Algérie
est en déclin désormais
donc il restait la Russie
et en ce qui concerne le GNL on est en
concurrence avec l'Asie en particulier
qui est un très très gros importateur de
GNL et il est pas du tout dit que quand
bien même on voudrait à court terme
retrouver les volumes qu'on avait avant
avant Poutine on va facilement y arriver
donc la et ça c'est pas quelque chose
que l'Europe il y avait pas de plan B
qui était prévu avant le déclenchement
de la de la guerre en Ukraine permettant
à l'Europe de se dire bon si jamais on
se fâche avec les Russes qu'est-ce qu'on
fait voilà ça il y avait pas de plan B
il y avait plutôt un plan B de se marier
avec les Russes notamment poussé par les
Allemands c'était à peu près ça la
stratégie européenne sur le pétrole
c'est pareil il y a pas de stratégie
européenne exactement l'Europe est
tellement confiante dans l'idée que la
décarbonation volontaire va aller
suffisamment vite qu'elle ne se
préoccupe pas de savoir comment est-ce
qu'elle se retourne si ça va pas assez
vite et où est la contrainte sur le plan
strictement géologique c'est un truc qui
est qui est un des angles morts de la
politique européenne est-ce que la crise
actuelle n'a quand même pas eu une vertu
c'est de nous faire prendre conscience
de notre dépendance à l'énergie oui
alors encore faut-il que elle n'arrive
pas trop tard et pas trop violemment si
vous jetez au niveau de la Tour Eiffel
au moment où vous écrasez par terre vous
prenez conscience de votre dépendance à
la gravitation
mais c'est un peu tard donc là on a
quand même
en matière en matière de dépendance en
fait on est quand même très en retard et
une des raisons ainsi d'Amand est liée à
une partie des gens qui sont
probablement dans cette salle c'est que
l'énergie en tant que sa forge les flux
physique n'est pas un facteur de
production dans les raisonnements
économiques donc c'est une commodité qui
s'achète mais c'est pas un facteur de
production qui forge les flux physique
et donc tous les gens à l'Europe qui ont
l'habitude de raisonner d'abord en se
basant sur des raisonnements économiques
c'est-à-dire qu'on considère que les
prix contiennent en gros la
quasi-totalité de l'information qui est
utile pour spéculer sur l'avenir ne
comprennent pas le côté strictement
physique de l'affaire et du coup quand
la physique nous prend au dépourvu ce
qui est le cas quand on a un
approvisionnement énergétique qui auront
rapidement on se retrouve partiellement
à poil c'est à dire que on se retrouve
dans dans ce contexte dans lequel on se
dit tiens ça marche plus comment on fait
il est il est urgent de mon point de vue
de
notamment en Europe de changer les
raisonnements alors ça commence à venir
à petite vitesse le monde qu'on a
construit le monde réglementaire de
l'Europe est quand même un monde qui est
fait enfin où c'est quand même un corpus
réglementaire qui est fait pour un monde
ouvert et facile
il se trouve que la contraction des flux
physiques vont rendre le monde moins
ouvert et moins facile
tout le monde nous dit la main sur le
cœur cette crise elle va accélérer la
transition mais ce qu'en réalité c'est
pas l'inverse qui est en train de se
produire on parlait il y a quelques
minutes de la réouverture de centrale à
charbon de de mine de charbon la
transition telle que l'Europe l'a conçue
jusqu'à maintenant est une croissance
verte et c'est fait de la manière
suivante faut de la croissance pour
avoir plus d'argent pour financer les
moyens qui vont permettre de se
décarboner en gros c'est comme ça que on
réfléchit
personne n'a
réfléchi à un plan de décroissance verte
c'est-à-dire d'abord on a des accidents
énergétiques du coup l'énergie se
contracte du coup on a moins de moyens
mais du coup avec les moyens qu'il en
reste il faut quand même qu'on accélère
bon ça c'est un cahier des charges qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas donc oui la
crise actuelle elle a la vertu de nous
réveiller
à moitié seulement parce que en fait les
gens qui passent au jour les décideurs
qui sont plus riches que la moyenne
passe aujourd'hui à travers la crise
sans trop de problèmes les gens qui sont
dans cette salle s'ils sont chauffés au
gaz ils vont voir leur facture de mais
enfin pas face à ce qui gagne il s'en
foutent donc ça va pas beaucoup les
gêner les gens qui vont vraiment être
gênés par ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment c'est pas les
décideurs
c'est aussi incidemment les gens qui
sont en train de gueuler pour leur
retraite les gens qui sont descendus
dans la rue il y a 3 ans tout ça c'est
les mêmes hein bon enfin c'est les mêmes
est-ce que la crise actuelle donc elle
permet aux gens qui décident de sentir
dans leur chair que vraiment il faut
qu'ils se réoriente rapidement alors un
petit peu s'ils sont pas trop
d'entreprise parce qu'ils peuvent
éventuellement voir leur entreprise
courir le risque d'aller au tapis donc
là oui effectivement mais en tant que
consommateur pas tellement parce que
encore une fois dans cette salle on fait
partie des CSP+ qui sont assez protégés
de l'écume des choses
il y a quand même un domaine dans lequel
l'Europe s'est réveillée c'est la
question de la structure de marché de
l'électricité là on s'est dit quand même
il va falloir qu'on fasse quelque chose
serait peut-être temps puisque en fait
ce qu'on a fait dans le sens inverse il
y a 20 ans était une ânerie donc voilà
on est en train de se rendre compte
mieux vaut tard que jamais comme disait
l'autre mais je n'ai pas l'impression de
ce que j'observe que ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment
occasionne une remise en cause
absolument fondamentale de la façon dont
on fonctionne et par ailleurs quand on
réfléchit à la décarbonation on l'a bien
vu dans la table ronde là qui vient
d'avoir lieu on raisonne moyen de
production
personne ne comprend que la
décarbonation c'est aussi la fin des
hypermarchés le fait que le Grand Paris
a 10 millions ça flotte pas et que les
produits agricoles vont voir leur prix
augmenter
c'est pas ça qui vient à l'esprit quand
on parle des carbonations
c'est on va faire des éoliennes quoi
c'est tout petit bout du problème
on va parler d'investissement puisque le
sujet est revenu plusieurs fois sur la
table ce matin Jean-Christophe café nous
parlait tout à l'heure de
d'investissement de 3,5 trillions de
dollars au cours des 10 prochaines
années uniquement dans le domaine de
l'énergie propre oui le contenu n'est
pas non mais je pense qu'il y sera
jamais je reviens à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure la civilisation dans
laquelle nous vivons elle est permise
par le fait que nous sommes sortis des
énergies renouvelables
c'est ça la civilisation dans laquelle
on vit vous portez je porte de la
pétrochimie vous allez manger à midi et
je vais manger du gaz et du Pétrole
pardon bon appétit bah oui tout ce qu'on
mange et pousse avec des engrais azotés
les engrais azotés sont faits du gaz
tout ce qu'on mange vient de chant vous
avez de la mécanisation et la
mécanisation c'est du pétrole du reste
les engins mécanisés sont faits avec de
l'acier qui fait du charbon donc vous
mangez littéralement du charbon du gaz
et du pétrole ou il y a absolument
les financements c'est pas le sujet ça a
été dit je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit et Christophe Fersen
tout à l'heure en fait le sujet c'est la
limite physique il suffit pas de faire
pleuvoir de l'argent pour avoir tout
d'un coup les compétences et le cuivre
pour faire des panneaux solaires c'est
pas juste un problème d'argent
les mines de cuivre étaient à 18% de
teneur en cuivre dans le minerai il y a
un siècle et demi maintenant c'est 0,4 %
vous pouvez mettre tout l'argent que
vous voulez dans le monde ça fera pas
revenir la teneur des minerais à 18%.
donc il y a une grosse méprise
aujourd'hui qui laisse penser que c'est
juste une affaire d'argent je pense que
c'est une méprise qui a été entretenue
par le monde financier qui peut ainsi
dire vous voyez on peut être du bon côté
de la barrière en mobilisant les
milliards mais en fait c'est pas juste
un problème d'argent cette histoire
c'est presque secondairement un problème
d'argent c'est un problème de
possibilité physique et c'est un
problème de compétence
donc la en ce qui concerne le
l'électricité je vais prendre l'exemple
de l'électricité aujourd'hui alors je
suis désolé je vais vous faire un peu
mal à la tête le stockage
électrochimique
c'est des transitions électroniques dans
des atomes de métal c'est ça le stockage
électrochimique c'est à dire que dans
une batterie en fait vous prenez des
atomes de métal vous excitez les
électrons et ça ça permet de stocker de
l'énergie une transition électronique
c'est quelques électrons volts par atome
et donc vous ne ferez jamais mieux avec
une batterie que le métal le plus léger
qu'on trouve sur terre qui est le
lithium puisque la transition
électronique quelques électrons volts
par électrons elle dépend pas du de la
masse du noyau donc vous prenez le
lithium trois protons vous ferez rien de
mieux bon aujourd'hui on va trier
électrochimique on sait donc faire 150
200 watts par kilo vous ferez jamais
2000 et vous ferez jamais 20000 c'est
pas une affaire d'argent si vous pouvez
mettre
tous les milliards que vous voulez sur
la table bon
en ce qui concerne l'électricité
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas stocker
l'électricité en tant que tel
l'électricité en tant que tel c'est un
électron qui se balade dans un métal en
tant que tel ça se stocke pas sauf dans
les supraconducteurs donc pour stocker
l'électricité il faut la transformer en
autre chose le stockage électrochimique
sera jamais à l'échelle des réseaux
électriques le seul truc qui pourrait
l'être c'est durant la remontée d'eau en
altitude sur des quantités massives ou
du gaz si vous voulez stocker de
l'électricité sous forme de gaz le
rendement de chaîne c'est 25%. vous
perdez 30% dans l'électrolyse 20% dans
la compression et vous reperdez 50%
quand vous faites passer de
l'électricité du gaz à l'électricité bon
donc c'est ça sera 25%
ce qui veut dire que tout électricité
que vous voulez stocker sur quelques
mois vous êtes obligé de la produire 4
fois plus grande quantité que ce que
vous allez finalement par utiliser finir
par utiliser quand vous déstockez vous
pouvez faire tous les milliards que vous
voulez sur la table vous allez pas
changer les rendements physiques de la
compression c'est la loi de Mariotte
vous allez pas changer c'est tout ça ne
changera pas donc c'est pas juste une
affaire de milliards en fait à un moment
les milliards n'y pourront rien ils font
il faut bien comprendre et le dernier
point que je voudrais indiquer c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les milliards ils sont
basés sur des coûts dans un système où
les énergies sont imbriquées personne il
n'y a pas un économiste au monde qui
soit capable de vous dire combien ça
coûte de fabriquer un panneau solaire
dans un monde qui n'a plus de pétrole
plus de gaz et plus de charbon
probablement beaucoup plus
considérablement plus d'abord c'est pas
sûr que vous pourrez les transporter
parce que dans un monde qui n'a plus de
pétrole plus de gaz et plus de charbon
les panneaux solaires fait en Chine ou
les amener en avec la marine à voile en
Europe bon à dos d'âne comme à l'époque
de Marco Polo bon donc
vous allez les fabriquer comment
aujourd'hui dans une éolienne vous avez
toute la chimie organique du monde bon à
partir du moment où vous avez plus de
pétrole comment vous faites etc donc en
fait aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de
désimbriquer les énergies dans les
raisonnements économiques donc tout ce
qu'on a vu c'est qu'on a fait la preuve
que dans un monde qui consomme de plus
en plus d'énergie fossiles on sait entre
autre chose faire une éolienne pour de
moins en moins cher ça ok il y a pas de
problème on en a fait la démonstration
est-ce que dans un monde qui consomme
très rapidement de moins en moins
d'énergie fossile
non seulement on conserve ce coût mais
on le voit pas comme le coup de
n'importe quoi de votre chemise de vos
chaussures des miennes et déchets
repartir vers le plafond aucun
économiste ne s'est penché sur la
question aujourd'hui donc les trillions
en plus ils sont calculés à consommation
énergétique fossile constante puisque
c'est ça qui fait la productivité du
système industriel donc les trillions ne
font pas tout et ils sont quand même
indispensables ce qui est indispensable
c'est la volonté et les moyens humains
et les ressources physiques
des trioms ça n'en est que la
matérialisation exposte du coup c'est
quoi la piste centrale c'est la sobriété
alors on va y passer de toute façon
alors la sobriété c'est un autre mot
pour la pauvreté ça dépend de la volonté
qu'on a en matière d'économie d'énergie
les ingénieurs aiment bien les
nomenclatures donc moi je me suis fait
une petite nomenclature qui consiste à
catégoriser les économies d'énergie
alors pour moi il y en a trois
catégories la première c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'efficacité l'efficacité c'est
vous utilisez la même voiture en fait le
même nombre de kilomètres elle a la même
masse elle va à la même vitesse
simplement elle consomme moins d'énergie
à l'usage ou à la fabrication et du coup
pour le même usage vous utilisez moins
d'énergie c'est un problème d'ingénieur
donc vous comme consommateur ça vous
contraint pas c'est pas votre problème
c'est le problème de l'appareil
productif
et par ailleurs c'est pas récessif
puisque ça vous force pas à diminuer
votre consommation
donc l'efficacité énergétique est un
truc que les gouvernements ont toujours
adoré tout le temps pour ces raisons là
la deuxième catégorie d'économie
d'énergie c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sobriété alors la sobriété dans mon dans
ma vision du monde est une démarche
volontaire de renoncement à un service
pour renoncer à la consommation
d'énergie afférentes donc là toujours
dans le même exemple vous n'utilisez
plus votre voiture vous utilisez un vélo
d'accord ça va utiliser considérablement
moins d'énergie par contre vous n'avez
plus le même service ça vous protège pas
aussi bien de la pluie ça vous protège
pas aussi bien des chocs vous n'avez pas
votre autoradio et vous allez moins loin
cela étant pour aller au boulot vous
avez pas besoin d'aller très loin
donc il y a quand même des cas de figure
dans lesquels on
qu'est-ce que je veux dire on peut
prendre le vélo
la troisième la troisième économie
d'énergie c'est ce que j'appelle la
pauvreté c'est exactement comme la
sobriété c'est à dire que vous vous
passez d'un service sauf que là on vous
a pas demandé votre avis vous avez juste
pas les moyens
donc l'énorme différence entre la
sobriété et la pauvreté n'est pas une
affaire de configuration technique c'est
le même genre de geste par contre dans
un cas vous avez l'impression d'être
maître de votre destin vous êtes auto
convaincu que c'est très bien de prendre
un vélo d'accord et donc là tout va bien
dans le deuxième cas de figure d'autres
ont décidé pour vous en vous empêchant
matériellement de le faire ou
financièrement de le faire et à ce
moment vous n'êtes pas content du tout
nous aurons à l'avenir nécessairement un
cocktail Détroit parce que comme les
arbres n'ont pas jusqu'au ciel les
combustibles fossiles je dédie tout à
l'heure vont baisser degré ou de force
et à partir du moment où il baisse degré
ou de force ça se fera par un mélange
d'efficacité c'est toujours bon à
prendre de sobriété pour ceux qui
voudront bien et de pauvreté pour ceux
qui voudront pas voilà c'est comme ça
que c'est comme ça que ça va se passer
il y a quand même une idée largement
répandue notamment aux États-Unis que la
technologie va venir nous sauver
recapture du carbone notamment et que
pour permettre à la technologie de nous
sauver il faut les investissements alors
la technologie jusqu'à maintenant c'est
appelé le moteur à combustion interne et
la machine à vapeur et elle a fait
passer les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 0 à 60 milliards de tonnes par
an
donc l'idée que la technologie est
autoporteuse du salut
à la technologie
a aussi fait les sucreries les
cigarettes et la pollution automobile la
technologie elle fait pas que le bien
quoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'à l'avenir tout d'un
coup les trous a été technique ne
feraient que le bien je vois pas
je vois pas donc l'idée que il suffit de
laisser les ingénieurs ingéniers et que
derrière ils vont trouver ce qu'il
faudra pour que ça nous sorte le bec de
l'eau sans qu'on ait besoin de nous les
consommateurs de se fatiguer je n'y
crois pas une seconde ça fait un siècle
et demi qu'on n'arrête pas d'avoir des
trous high techniques et ça fait un
siècle et demi que les émissions
n'arrêtent pas d'augmenter prenez par
exemple ce très bel écran que j'ai en
face de moi c'est tout à fait de la
trouvaille technique
l'empreinte carbone du digital
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est 4% des
émissions mondiales c'est-à-dire à peu
près deux fois les émissions du
transport aérien et ça augmente de 5 à
10% par an je vous rassure et va être
réutilisé il y a peut-être réutilisé en
général c'est pas jetable ces trucs là
mais donc il n'empêche que le système
digital c'est 4% des émissions par an
voilà donc est-ce que cette technologie
nous a aidé à faire baisser les
émissions non
absolument pas je pourrais même être
encore plus illustratif si demain matin
je supprimais le système digital mondial
c'est assez facile de comprendre que ça
mettrait un énorme coup d'arrêt à
l'économie
donc c'est bien la preuve que le Digital
est globalement un inducteur d'émission
c'est un lubrifiant de l'économie
mondiale sans ça il y a plus de finances
plus de monnaie certains nombre de
petits trucs qui lubrifient l'économie
mondiale et donc l'économie se contracte
très fortement donc voilà une
démonstration du fait que le Digital a
pas du tout c'est une proie technique
pas du tout permis d'éviter des
émissions moi puis je pourrais reprendre
plein d'autres exemples donc l'idée que
demain matin la technologie tout d'un
coup va devenir le Messie j'y crois pas
une seconde la capturer séquestration du
carbone pour prendre cet exemple
c'est quelque chose dont on parle depuis
que je m'intéresse au sujet donc vous
savez il y a des sujets comme ça en fait
vous les prenez à 20 ans d'intervalle et
à 20 ans d'intervalle c'est toujours un
truc qui va venir vous sauver dans 20
ans c'était également le vrai pour la
fusion
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que la capture
est extraction du carbone ça consiste à
récupérer le CO2 dans les fumées
d'installation de combustion de grande
taille pour éviter qu'ils partent dans
l'atmosphère et l'enfouir sous terre le
CO2 en question
c'est pour récupérer le CO2 qui est une
molécule chimiquement inerte c'est un
oxyde donc c'est une molécule chimique
moyenne dans de la fumée il faut
dépenser beaucoup d'énergie et en fait
le procédé de capture il supprime à peu
près 20 à 30 % enfin il consomme plus
exactement à peu près 20 à 30 % de
l'énergie de l'installation vous
cherchez capturer le CO2 ce qui est une
autre manière de dire que vous supprimez
20 à 30% de la production du site en
question quand vous mettez en oeuvre
cette capture et séquestration donc si
vous avez une centrale électrique vous
allez supprimer 20 à 30% de la
production électrique si vous avez une
cimenterie vous allez supprimer 20 à 30%
de la production de ciment etc enfin
Simon c'est moins vrai parce que c'est
une partie c'est du c'est de la réaction
chimique ce qui veut dire que mettre en
oeuvre ce procédé à large échelle va
avec une pénalité énergétique
qui va très fortement
contracter
la production du système économique
sous-jacent et en fait c'est ça le
premier problème de la capturer
séquestration c'est pas du tout le
traduit traduire ça en coût ne reflète
pas cette réalité
si vous dites le prix de mes chemises va
augmenter de 20 % ou de 30 %, c'est
totalement différent de ma production de
chemise va diminuer 30%
on parle pas exactement la même chose et
donc là c'est bien ça le c'est bien ça
le premier problème
en plus il faut casser les centrales
électriques à charbon et utiliser des
procédés de combustion différents pour
être capable de mettre en oeuvre ce
procédé dans les centrales à charbon
enfin bref donc c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est anecdotique dans le
monde on a on aimait 40 milliards de
tonnes de CO2 par an dans le monde les
procédés de capture actuellement en
vigueur c'est quelques dizaines de
millions de tonnes
et là dedans vous avez notamment de la
séparation CO2 gaz naturel en tête
depuis dans un certain nombre d'endroits
où on vous interdit formellement de
faire circuler du gaz dans les gaz
auducs avec du CO2 dedans voilà donc
c'est quelque chose que les pétroliers
s'affairent depuis longtemps
notamment pour cette raison pas pour
d'autres raisons parmi vos nombreuses
casquettes vous faites du conseil aux
entreprises on a un panel assez large
ici aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les entreprises se sont
suffisamment emparées du problème alors
la réponse courte et non et pour si on
considère que l'indicateur quantitatif
que nous avons que nous devons avoir en
tête c'est que pour tenir les deux
degrés il faut que les émissions
planétaires baissent de 5% par an
aujourd'hui des entreprises qui ont un
business plan compatible avec des
émissions qui baissent de 5% par an j'en
connais pas beaucoup parce que en fait
des émissions qui baissent de 5% par an
c'est un nouveau covid tous les ans
je pense pas que le business plan de la
Coface soit compatible avec ça et je ne
pense pas que le business plan de qui
que ce soit aujourd'hui sauf
éventuellement mon boulanger soit
compatible avec ce genre de choses donc
les entreprises alors en plus les
entreprises il faut bien voir que dalgan
on mélange à la fois des multinationales
mon boulanger mon maraîcher et le
serrurier
qui fait les doubles de clés tout ça
c'est des entreprises bon
est-ce que donc est-ce que globalement
les entreprises
ont réfléchi à ce que ça voulait dire
pour elle un monde à deux degrés la
réponse est non
en général dans beaucoup d'entreprises
la réflexion sudation c'est-à-dire que
d'abord elles font ce qu'elles
s'affaires elles disent que ce qu'elles
font est vachement bien il va contribuer
à la solution et ensuite seulement elle
réfléchissent je vais plutôt comme ça
dans ce sens là que ça se passe
les seuls qui font le chemin inverse
c'est les entreprises naissantes tiens
les entreprises qui se créent autour
d'un projet qui lui est déjà aligné je
connais des gens par exemple ils montent
actuellement des ateliers de réparation
de vélo alors c'est des petites
entreprises mais ça c'est typiquement
des entreprises dans lesquelles d'entrée
de jeu la personne s'est mise
a fait le chemin inverse d'abord elle
réfléchit au problème se dit qu'est-ce
que dans un monde où les émissions
baissent rapidement ou les gens vont
avoir moins de voitures etc de quoi ils
vont avoir besoin ah tiens il va avoir
besoin de vélo les vélos ça crève de
temps en temps il y a la chaîne qui
saute donc je vais faire un atelier de
réparation de vélo voilà
mais globalement les entreprises
installées elles cherchent à conserver
leur rente carbonate comme les autres du
reste parce que c'est ça la règle du jeu
et donc à ce moment c'est très très
compliqué de se réinventer de fond en
comble or quand on parle d'émission qui
baissent de 5 % par an j'insiste sur le
fait que on est en train de parler d'un
de d'un chamboulement complet et
permanent et donc les entreprises
aujourd'hui que avec lesquelles on
travaille globalement elles sont pas à
ce niveau là est-ce que ça veut dire que
c'est inutile de leur parler on espère
que non sinon on ferait pas le métier
qu'on fait est-ce que ça veut dire que
elles ne peuvent absolument rien faire
la réponse est non sinon on ferait pas
le métier qu'on fait mais si on doit
répondre très honnêtement à la question
qui est-ce qu'aujourd'hui elles sont au
bon niveau la réponse est NON à part les
ateliers de réparation de vélo et les et
les startups est-ce qu'il y a quand même
des secteurs qui tirent leur épingle du
jeu
oui un peu plus vertueux on va dire il y
a des secteurs qui se retrouvent par la
force des choses du bon côté de la
barrière
si vous fabriquez de la laine de verre
que vous avez des centrales nucléaires
ou vous tirez des trains
le hasard vous l'avez pas fait pour des
raisons climat tout ça
Alstom EDF et Saint-Gobain sont des
entreprises qui sont pas nées depuis
qu'on s'excite sur le changement
climatique
donc si le hasard de la vie vous a mis
du bon côté de la barrière vous pouvez
très bien avoir des activités qui sont
des activités qui sont tout à fait
pertinentes dans un monde qui doit se
décarboner
mais j'insiste sur le fait que c'est
souvent le hasard de la vie qui les a
mis là dans les grosses entreprises
on voit la multiplication des
initiatives pour orienter l'offre
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire pour que
la transition ça passe aussi par la
demande c'est très compliqué parce que
ça revient quelque part à ce qu'on ait
envie de se mettre au régime donc c'est
le c'est la question de la sobriété que
j'ai évoquais tout à l'heure or se
mettre au régime avec que des
inconvénients on n'aime pas ça je veux
dire on est ainsi fait que on n'aime pas
trop ce genre de truc et donc en fait ce
qu'il faut arriver c'est à vendre la
sobriété par ses à-côtés qui sont
positifs
lorsque il y a des démarches d'économie
d'énergie alors je vais prendre deux
exemples il va le ce qu'il valent mais
c'est pour me faire comprendre parler
tout à l'heure des chaussettes moi je
sais pas qui dans la salle aime dormir
dans une pièce surchauffée mais il y a
plein de gens qui aiment pas ça donc le
fait de dire baisser donc le thermostat
et rajouter une couette ce qui est un
mesure de sobriété vous pouvez
éventuellement le vendre aussi avec un à
côté immédiat qui a rien à voir avec
l'énergie qui est que vous allez passer
une meilleure nuit
reprenons l'exemple du vélo je pense que
même si demain matin il y a on disait en
fait le vélo ça sert à rien pour la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
il y a plein de gens qui continueraient
à en faire parce que ça leur fait faire
un peu d'exercice parce qu'ils n'ont pas
le stress d'être coincé dans les
bouchons parce qu'ils ont pas ce que ça
leur coûte moins cher et que ils se
disent avec l'argent que je dégage je
peux faire autre chose parce que etc
donc en fait dans les économies et dans
les comportements sobre on a besoin de
se creuser un peu la cervelle pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
trouver ça sympathique pour des raisons
qui ne sont pas la raison première qui
est que on va faire avec moins de
quelque chose parce que les animaux que
nous sommes encore une fois en général
faire moins quand c'était faire plus qui
était dans notre imaginaire ce qui était
valorisé c'est quelque chose qui reste
un peu compliqué et on a besoin de
déplacer le faire plus ailleurs en
disant regardez ça c'est quand même ça
qui est sympa et puis du coup ça va nous
permettre d'aller dans la bonne
direction quand on parle de demande vous
dites personne n'aime se mettre au
régime mais ce qu'on peut pas compter
sur les jeunes générations nous on a été
habitués à vivre différemment les jeunes
générations peuvent apprendre alors ici
vivre dès le départ différemment oui il
y a d'abord l'impression de se mettre au
régime absolument alors il y a ça dépend
pourquoi il y a des domaines dans
lesquels les jeunes générations ont
quand même du mal à se mettre au régime
si je prends l'avion par exemple la
consommation d'avion elle est maximale
dans la tranche 25,34 ans
et la deuxième tranche où elle est
maximale c'est juste c'est celle des
encore plus jeune c'est à dire les 16
les 16 24 ans si je prends le digital
Tik Tok les jeunes sont quand même
globalement des gros consommateurs de
Digital par contre en matière
d'alimentation par exemple et bien ils
sont plus facilement sobre sur les
produits carnés que la génération qu'il
est précède
il y a un certain nombre de jeunes
urbains qui se passent plus facilement
de voiture que la génération qui les a
précédés voilà donc ça ça va vraiment
dépendre
je pense que les jeunes ils ont un petit
côté ambivalent
par ailleurs alors qu'il soit préoccupé
ça c'est absolument certain que dans
leur comportement effectif
il soit plus vertueux sur tous les plans
il faut nuancer un peu
vous parliez tout à l'heure des
inégalités sociales face aux changements
vous parliez des SSP CSP+ qui peuvent
payer un petit peu plus cher leur
facture de gaz et ce qui est aussi des
inégalités géographiques j'imagine et on
le sait tous que tous les pays ne sont
pas au même niveau face au changement
climatique alors ni face au changement
climatique ni face à l'énergie alors
dans les pays occidentaux mais il y a un
truc qui m'a toujours beaucoup amusé
c'est le cash-sexe de la consommation
d'énergie des pays émergents oui mais
eux ils ont bien le droit de consommer
en fait si les pays émergents ça nous
préoccupait tant que ça il y a longtemps
que les Français seraient d'accord pour
que 10% de leurs impôts ou 20% de leurs
impôts
partent dans ces pays-là ce qui n'est
pas vraiment le cas donc leur sort ne
nous a jamais autant préoccupé depuis
qu'il était question de nous priver nous
sur la partie du climat oui bien
évidemment il va y avoir en fait ce qui
va permettre de réagir
aux caprices du climat enfin ce qui
permet de ne pas trop démunis dans un
premier temps face aux caprice du climat
c'est précisément l'abondance
énergétique parce que qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait l'abondance énergétique il y a pas
assez d'eau vous iriez c'est de
l'énergie ça pousse plus ici vous
l'importez de là c'est de l'énergie vous
avez trop chaud vous mettez en route la
clim c'est de l'énergie vous avez une
infrastructure qui est détruite par une
inondation vous la reconstruisez
rapidement c'est de l'énergie donc en
fait il faut bien voir que ce qui permet
aujourd'hui de faire face à un début
d'adversité c'est l'énergie et donc les
pays qu'on appelle pauvre en fait c'est
pour des raisons strictement physiques
puisque l'économie c'est des machines au
travail en fait c'est des pays qui ont
un approvisionnement énergétique faible
c'est ça les pays pauvres
qui sont pas nécessairement pauvres dans
l'absolu ils ont des actifs naturels
quelquefois qui sont supérieurs aux
autres certains nombres d'entre eux ont
une espérance de vie des États-Unis
enfin bon voilà donc
mais par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que
ils ont moins de d'énergie c'est-à-dire
moins de machines au travail et donc
quand il y a un coup du sort qui leur
tombe dessus et bien c'est plus
difficile d'y faire face je vais prendre
un exemple deux ouragans Bangladesh d'un
côté Katrina de l'autre aux États-Unis
sous perfusion d'énergie Catherine a
fait 1500 morts parce que arrive
immédiatement les gens qui amènent de
l'eau potable qui empêchent les émeutes
qui amènent de la bouffe qui évacue les
gens etc donc au Bangladesh le même le
même ouragan fait 100000 morts
parce que les gens se mettent à boire de
l'eau croupie et en fait ça va être
essentiellement le choléra qui va tuer
les gens c'est pas l'ouragan au moment
où il est passé c'est les conséquences
derrière
là on voit une illustration parfaite de
l'inégalité face au caprice du système
climatique et du rôle de l'énergie
absolument centrale dans le fait d'être
capable d'y résister alors les pays
d'impôts donc il voudrait avoir des
moyens
de se développer donc c'est clair qu'il
y a un vrai sujet qui est que tant que
nous on vit comme on vit eux disent il y
a pas de raison que nous on n'est pas la
même chose donc on va être un peu mal
placé pour leur faire la leçon tant que
nous on fait pas des efforts et par
ailleurs effectivement face aux caprices
du climat plus vous avez de moyens
matériels et plus c'est facile dans une
certaine mesure je dis bien dans une
certaine mesure de vous en prémunir
c'est pas les moyens matériels qui
feront revenir la forêt française si
elle meurt
parce qu'il y a pas de moyens matériels
qui fasse pousser un arbre en une
semaine plutôt qu'un 50 ans
le monde d'après idéalement décarboné ne
peut pas ressembler au monde d'avance ça
fait trois quarts d'heure vous ne
l'expliquer
cela dit vous nous parlez de
décroissance
c'est ça le monde d'après c'est
forcément la décroissance la
décroissance des flux physiques est
inexorable oui
la décroissance économique elle sera ce
que sera la Convention
oui c'est court
alors je vais essayer d'élaborer un peu
oui
le flux physique en
physique l'énergie est une unité de
quantification du changement c'est à ça
que ça sert donc vous avez de l'énergie
quand vous quantifiez un changement de
température de vitesse de composition
chimique éventuellement de forme module
de jungershort etc enfin bref donc
l'énergie partout en physique c'est ce
qui sert à quantifier un changement donc
moins d'énergie c'est par définition en
physique moins de changement donc à
partir du moment vous avez moins de
changements vous avez moins de
transformation de minerai de fer en
fourchette vous avez moins de
transformation de ver à soi en écharpe
et vous avez moins de transformation de
sable en verre voilà par définition donc
un monde qui se contracte sur le plan
énergétique et il va se contracter sur
le plan énergétique de toute façon est
un monde dans lequel les flux physiques
se contractent alors après vous pouvez
décider que on valorise chaque année le
verre le double de l'année précédente
auquel cas ça pose pas de problème
d'avoir un pib-croissant mais ça ne pour
autant fera pas plus de verres par
je vais vous prendre un exemple issu de
la de l'actualité très récente la grande
distribution ça fait maintenant un peu
moins d'un an qu'elle voit à la fois les
achats augmentaient en valeur et les
achats diminuent en volume
c'est un effet de l'inflation bon pour
être très bien décidé qu'on arrête de
corriger l'inflation c'est-à-dire que un
poulet qui a passé la grippe aviaire et
bien ils vont pas le même prix qu'un
poulet qui a pas passé la grippe aviaire
c'est pas le même produit d'accord c'est
pas le même produit puisque là on va
passer la grippe aviaire et pas l'autre
et donc c'est normal qu'il va être pas
le même prix d'accord donc il y a pas
lieu de corriger de l'inflation si on
fait ce genre de choses on peut avoir un
PIB indéfiniment croissant avec un
approvisionnement énergétique
indéfiniment décroissant mais ça fait
quand même moins de poulet
donc si ce que vous voulez compter avec
le PIB c'est les choses vraies les
choses qui se touchent qu'il s'agissent
de produits ou de services qui se
touchent par exemple un colloque c'est
un service qui se touche il faut une
salle il faut que les gens viennent il
faut les moyens de transport etc c'est
un service qui se touche et bien si vous
voulez avoir
si vous avez une baisse de l'énergie la
quantité de produits qui se touche et de
services qui se touchent vous en aurez
quand même moins
voilà c'est bon est-ce qu'on va échapper
pas plus que vous n'allez échapper à
votre vieillissement et moi ou bien
j'avais prévu de vous demander si vous
étiez optimiste ou pessimiste pour
l'avenir c'était ma dernière question
elle était écrite noire mais j'ai un peu
peur de la réponse que la poser je pense
que la réponse c'est que vous avez plus
de chance d'être optimiste si vous êtes
réaliste dit autrement si aujourd'hui on
vit dans le déni je pense que on ne on
accroît la probabilité de devenir
pessimiste dans pas très longtemps si on
n'est pas déjà donc si on veut qu'est-ce
que c'est quatre optimiste finalement
c'est considéré qu'on a toujours la
maîtrise de son destin et qu'on a de la
prise sur ce qui va nous arriver
et bien la prise qui va sur ce qui va
nous arriver c'est plus facile si vous
êtes réaliste que si vous n'êtes pas
réaliste je reprends l'exemple de votre
vieillissement quand mon âge vous aurait
et bien à ce moment si vous fixez des
défis à la hauteur des possibilités de
votre carcasse vous avez plus de chance
d'y arriver que si vous vous fixez des
défis à la hauteur des possibilités de
votre carcasse quand vous aviez 20 ans
d'accord et vous aurez quand même une
vie plus sympa si vous fixez des défis
que vous relevez que si vous vous fixez
des défis pour lesquels vous plantez bon
donc vous voyez bien que un peu de
réalisme
ça peut ça peut aider à être optimiste
et je pense que en ce qui concerne le
sujet que je viens d'évoquer c'est
exactement ça qu'il faut avoir donc il
faut avoir du réalisme alors le réalisme
au début c'est un peu désagréable parce
que ça oblige quand même à abandonner un
certain nombre de croyances et un
certain nombre de méthodes aujourd'hui
je reprends l'exemple de l'économie on a
quand même une capacité à piloter notre
avenir pour les retraites comme pour le
reste en pensant que on va pouvoir
dériver des chiffres économiques passés
les chiffres économiques futurs en
faisant l'économie pardon de la
répétition du raisonnement physique
sous-jacent
ça c'est le plus sur moyen de se planter
et de devenir pessimiste voilà donc il
faut arriver à trouver d'autres modes de
raisonnement qui repassent par les
réalités physiques de ce monde et c'est
comme ça qu'on a une petite chance de
devenir optimiste merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc Jancovici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]